bluff ou pas la bombe atomique nord
coréenne pyongyang affirme avoir l'armé
nucléaire par mesures d'autodéfense et
interpelle les états unis réponse
aujourd'hui de la maison blanche qui
refuse de discuter en tout cas pour les
experts la corée du nord exerçant un
chantage pour tenter de sortir de son
isolement
les explications de serge kovacs larmes
suprême aux mains d'un dernier régime
stalinien de la planète
puis on viande l'affirment haut et fort
la corée du nord possède des bombes
atomiques fabriqués dans cette centrale
nucléaire et l'aurait même la capacité
d'en produire une douzaine voilà ce que
prétend le dictateur kim jong-il
un homme qui disposait déjà de missiles
balistiques capables de frapper
n'importe quel pays d'asie
la nouvelle annonce a été faite hier par
la télévision d'état l'imi nous avons
fabrier les deux atomique ça la
politique de moins en moins déguisée de
l'administration bush
thibault isolé étouffer la république
populaire démocratique de corée
ce n'est pas la première fois que kim
jong il brandit la menace de l'armé
nucléaire depuis deux ans il s'en vante
à plusieurs reprises mais jusqu'à
présent rien n'a permis de vérifier
l'existence d'un tel arsenal 6
d'ici un an les nord-coréens n'ont rien
montré et surtout n'ont pas fait
d'essais on sera en état de leur dur et
vous avait bluffé on vous croit pas les
américains sont donc très sceptiques
comme donald rumsfeld le secrétaire à la
défense
il se demande si la corée du nord ne
cherche pas avant tout à extorquer de
nouvelles concessions qui veulent des
garanties de non agression
ils veulent également ned économies des
états unis sur le plan énergétique et
sur le plan alimentaire
ceux qui veulent surtout c'est la survie
de leur intérêt en tant que régime
la corée du nord a rompu hier les
négociations engagées en août 2003 avec
six pays dont la chine
elles réclament un dialogue direct avec
washington mais les états unis ne
veulent rien savoir
pas question de céder aux pressions de
kim jong il
l'homme qui règne en maître à pyongyang